hey guys it's fresh and clean vadim for
max tech and as you know
apple's wwdc just happened and they've
left us with a ton of new features and
changes
with the new ios 15 update which
surprisingly is going to be available on
iphones as old as the iphone 6s
so what i'm gonna do in this video is
weed out all of the changes
that aren't that big of a deal and just
focus on the best features and changes
that'll actually make your life better
on a daily basis
so let's get started with the first new
feature which is the newly redesigned
notification center
with changes that people have been
asking for for years
we've now got contact photos for
messages and contacts within your
notifications
as well as larger icons for apps to make
them easier to see
there's also the new notification
summary which you can schedule to get
delivered to you
at whatever time you choose and it uses
machine learning and your past activity
to put the most relevant and important
notifications at the top
and the least important at the bottom
this is going to be really awesome for
those notifications that come throughout
the day
but aren't urgent like a text message
which will always show up
instantly like a regular notification
and of course you can enable do not
disturb if you're busy
and one big change this year is that
someone else using imessage
will be able to see that you've silenced
your notifications
before they text you and if it's an
emergency
they can push it through by tapping
notify anyway
apple is taking it even further with
their new focus modes
like personal work sleep or a custom
focus
if you want to make one like for example
doing your homework
this is going to allow only the
notifications related to each focus
group to come through
so you won't get distracted with work
related notifications
while you're with your family at home
and you can even customize the apps and
people that are allowed to give you
notifications
while you're in each focus group and
even better it works across
all of your icloud devices so you can
easily turn it on using your apple watch
if that's more convenient for you moving
on the next awesome feature is
all of the huge changes made to facetime
the biggest deal
is that facetime is now finally opened
up to non-apple users
so you can create a scheduled meeting
and share a link with others so they can
join in
no matter which device they're on so
basically apple is putting zoom out of
business
because all of this is going to be
completely free and everything will have
end-to-end encryption that you can trust
on top of that one huge surprise is the
new portrait mode feature which is
supported on iphone
ipad or m1 max so the background is
going to be blurred out
so your friends and family can focus on
your face and i've got to say
this is basically hinting at apple
bringing portrait mode video to the
iphone
hopefully as soon as the iphone 13 since
that was already in the rumor mill
on top of that audio is getting improved
with both a new voice isolation feature
which gets rid of background noise and
then a wide spectrum mode
which makes background noise louder
which could potentially be useful in
some scenarios
another cool feature is share play which
allows you to share content like music
or movies with your friends
as you facetime them you can even watch
a movie together
at the same time since it syncs between
both of you
which is honestly really impressive and
since apple opened up the shareplay api
with other developers
it might be coming to apps like youtube
so you can share and show videos
with your friends but my personal
favorite part of shareplay
is that you can share your screen with
someone who needs help
with finding a setting or anything else
on their phone now moving on to the next
major change
the wallet app is now finally gonna
support various keys and badges
using the new ultra wide band chip which
is already packed into every iphone 11
and iphone 12.
for example some new cars are getting
support for apple's car key feature
so you'll be able to walk up to your car
and unlock it with just your phone
and apple is basically working on
bringing every sort of key to the wallet
app
like your house keys with specific
third-party locks
your hotel room using your iphone or
apple watch
and even your workplace if your company
supports it but apple isn't stopping
there they're allowing you to scan your
id or driver's license right into the
wallet app
so you don't have to worry about
carrying it around and apparently apple
is already working with the tsa at
airports
to get iphone identification support
this is basically ushering in
the future where we no longer need to
carry everything around with us
and i wouldn't be surprised if apple is
going to be bringing passport ids
onto iphones very soon the next great
feature that is really going to help
with
everyday life has to do with the airpods
first up there's the conversation boost
feature for airpods pro
which will amplify the voice of someone
you're talking to
and allow you to dial down the ambient
noise at the same time
which is going to be perfect for people
who require hearing aids
on top of that siri can now
automatically read your notifications to
you
and she can even read your shopping list
to you as your shopping
which is really convenient now one of
the worst things about airpods was that
they were pretty easy to lose
but now the same find my features that
came to the air tags
are now on the airpods so they can be
located by other apple devices
as people walk by them and now you can
even play
a sound to them even while they're in
the case
and use the new proximity feature to
find them but the best part of all is
the new separation
alert feature which will let you know
when you accidentally dropped your
earpods and left them behind somewhere
now moving on to the next one siri is
finally getting a new feature that i
personally wanted for years
and that's offline mode now you no
longer have to be connected to the
internet to use siri
so let's say you're out camping and you
have no service
and you simply want to set a timer you
can now finally do it with
no internet service and the reason apple
is able to do this because with the new
update
the audio never leaves your iphone
everything is processed
on device using the neural engine which
gives you a couple of advantages
it's now much more secure and private
and on top of that
siri is much faster than before since
everything is processed
on device and all of that is part of
apple's continued push for privacy
so let's get into the new privacy
features which help keep your data
safe and secure each and every day
apple's new mail privacy protection
gives you some amazing features for free
like hiding your ip address hiding your
location
and even disabling read receipts so
newsletters and advertisers
won't be able to tell if you opened an
email or not on top of that when you're
browsing the web with safari
apple automatically hides your ip
address from trackers
and you now get a new app privacy report
which will tell you the various ways
apps access your private data like your
photos webcam
contacts microphone and more within the
last seven days
even better you'll be able to see the
third-party domains that the app is
contacting
and giving your data to which is
basically facebook's
worst nightmare so it's gonna be
interesting to see how they respond
but the absolute bombshell feature that
blew my mind
is apple's new private relay feature for
people who pay for icloud plus
your internet browsing traffic gets
relayed twice so that no one
including apple can see all of your
browsing data
which basically means that it's a
reliable vpn
built into safari which is huge because
you don't have to pay
for any third-party service and on top
of that apple also has a new hide my
email feature
which lets you create single use email
addresses
that automatically forward to your
actual email account
just in case companies start sending you
a bunch of spam
and if that does end up happening you
can simply disable that specific burner
email address
and not have to worry about it now on
top of those privacy features
safari is getting some major updates
like a new redesign
with the focus on tab management with
new tab groups that you can customize
there's a new tab bar on the bottom of
the page that allows you to swipe
between the tab groups and swipe up to
reveal all the taps
there's also a new customizable start
page which automatically syncs with the
mac as well
and i think one of the most important
new features is web extensions
finally coming to the iphone and ipad so
now extensions like honey or something
else
will not be limited to just the mac and
to make it even better
extensions share code with existing
safari
extensions on the mac so it's going to
be incredibly quick and easy
for developers to bring them over to the
iphone and ipad and finally
there's a feature that i've been waiting
for for years and that's automatic
translation
you can now simply open up the translate
app and have a conversation with someone
else
both in your own native languages and
it'll automatically translate everything
for you on the fly
and on top of that you have system-wide
translation
so you can select text anywhere you see
it and tap
translate but perhaps the coolest
feature of all is able to translate text
within a
photo that you take which is useful for
when you're going on vacations to
foreign places
and that works by using apple's new live
text feature
which allows you to take photos of text
and then select it
which can be super convenient so there
you guys go those are all of the new ios
15 features that actually matter in the
real world
for everyday life so if you enjoyed this
video go ahead and click the circle
above because we've got a whole lot more
videos coming soon
definitely check out one of those two
right there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next video
you